AND IT SHOULD BE.
I'M GLAD THAT OTHER PEOPLE
ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
NOW AND NOT JUST US.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: A FORMER MEMBER
OF THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMISSION A SENIOR LEGAL
FELLOW JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT THE OBAMA CAMPAIGN
RECEIVED THIS DATE THAT THAT
WOULD BE INKIND
CONTRIBUTION, CORRECT.
>> IT IS VERY VALUABLE DATA.
FORMER MEDIA DIRECTOR FOR
THE OBAMA CAMPAIGN SAID
FACEBOOK ACTUALLY CAME TO
THEIR OFFICE AND SAID WELL,
WE DON'T NORMALLY GIVE THIS
DATA OUT BUT WE'RE GOING TO
LET YOU HAVE IT BECAUSE WE
FAVOR YOUR CAMPAIGN.
THAT TURNS IT INTO
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL
CONTRIBUTION.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD THAT
NOT BE ILLEGAL AND NOT BE A
CRIME.
>> IF THEY MADE THIS DATA
AVAILABLE TO NIBBLE WHO
WANTS IT, WELL THEN, OF
COURSE, ANY CAMPAIGN TO GET
IT BUT THE FACT THAT THEY
SPECIFICALLY HAD RULES
AGAINST THIS, DOES MAKE IT
AN INKIND CONTRIBUTION.
CONTRAST THIS WITH WHAT THEY
DID WITH CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA, REMEMBER,
CAMBRIDGE ANALYTICA WHEN
THEY FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS,
THEY WENT TO CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA AND SAID YOU NEED
TO DESTROY THIS DATA.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE
IT.
THAT TELLS YOU THAT IN THE
ONE CASE THEY LET THE
CAMPAIGN HAVE IT.
IN ANOTHER CASE THEY WERE
SAYING WELL, NO, YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE THIS DATA.
>> Tucker: SO FACEBOOK, BUT
ALSO GOOGLE AND TWITTER AND
APPLE, THE BIG TECH
COMPANIES COULD EASILY THROW
AN ELECTION AND WE WOULDN'T
KNOW IT AND SO WE SHOULD BE
TERRIFIED OF THIS.
I DON'T THINK WE ARE
TERRIFIED ENOUGH.
BUT, WHAT IS THE U.S.
CONGRESS, WHAT ARE THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCIES AND THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE HUGE
COMPANIES WHO HAVE MORE
POWER THAN ANY COMPANIES
HAVE EVER HAD IN HUMAN
HISTORY ARE REMAINING
TRANSPARENT?
I MEAN, WE ARE CERTAIN THIS
IS NOT HAPPENING.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO ASSURE
US OF THAT.
>> IN THE CASE OF THE OBAMA
CAMPAIGN POTENTIALLY GETTING
CORPORATE CONTRIBUTION WHICH
SILL LEGAL, THAT OUGHT TO BE
INVESTIGATED BY THE FEDERAL
ELECTION COMMISSION WHERE I
USED TO BE A COMMISSIONER
BECAUSE IT'S A POTENTIAL
VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW.
>> Tucker: IS IT --
>> NO IDEA WHERE THEY ARE
GOING TO OPEN UP AN
INVESTIGATION.
POTENTIALLY ALSO THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COULD
INVESTIGATE IT BECAUSE IF IT
WAS AN INTENTIONAL AND
KNOWING VIOLATION OF THE
LAW, THAT TAKES IT FROM
BEING A CIVIL VIOLATION TO A
CRIMINAL VIOLATION.
SO, BOTH OF THOSE FEDERAL
AGENCIES HAVE POTENTIAL
JURISDICTION OVER.
THIS SO FAR, NO ONE HAS SAID
AT ANY OF THOSE AGENCIES
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO OPEN
UP AN INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY OUGHT TO DO
THOUGH.
>> Tucker: YEAH.